- [Narrator] Does the
president's party usually gain
or lose seats at the midterm elections?
- It's a pretty strong historical trend
that the president's party
loses seats in the presidency.
So that's particularly the case
in the House of Representatives.
Since the Civil War,
about 93% of the time,
the president's party loses seats.
Now sometimes they lose a lot of seats
and the entire control
of the House switches
from control in the president's party
to control into the other party.
In the Senate it's a little less direct.
About 70% of the time,
the president's party
loses seats in a midterm election.
And this is often seen, and
more in more recent history,
it's really seen as a kinda
thumbs up or thumbs down vote
on how the president is doing.
The electorate reacting to
whether they like or dislike
what the president is doing.
And in the two cases recently,
where the president's
party did pick up seats
in Congress, it was in
1998 when the Republicans
were seen to have overreached
in their impeachment
of Bill Clinton, and so
voters voted for Democrats,
Bill Clinton's party.
And then in 2002 when
George W. Bush was seen
as successfully responding
to the 2001 attacks
on the World Trade Center
and the Pentagon and America,
his party picked up seats in
the Congressional election
because it was seen as a ratification
of his presidency so far.